habrían tenido que llegar lejos cannes
burgos brazzaville lagos o abiyán pero a
causa de la pandemia sus viajes fueron
cancelados entonces llegaron desde gabón
ghana pero la mayoría vive aquí en togo
como es el modelo en áfrica es casi una
profesión sigue siendo una pasión pocas
veces es un trabajo fácil
en el marco de la octava edición del
festival internacional de moda de nome
hablan sobre su experiencia abiertamente
vengan muchas niñas sueñan con ser
modelos pero desafortunadamente no es
una profesión muy bien vista y algunas
familias no aceptan que sus hijas entren
a la industria preferirían que estudie
modelar no impide seguir estudiando yo
no dejé de ir al colegio por ejemplo
pero aunque a algunas personas les guste
mucho la idea de ser modelos realmente
no pueden expresar lo porque no se
considera una opción viable de carrera
en gabón
[Aplausos]
el modelaje es una manera de mostrar el
valor de la mujer africana
y también es una manera de evadirse de
expresarse personalmente
de hacer lo que uno quiera y de lograr
lo que uno quiera a través del
comportamiento no es fácil ser modelo en
togo realmente hay que trabajar para
encontrar agencias mientras que en
occidente hay personas que te patrocinan
hay que hay que hacerlo todo por cuenta
propia y eso incluye encontrar una buena
agencia para poder independizarse
se elimine recibe en su casa vive con su
esposo en vida a las afueras de lomé
el modelo desde hace 8 años
reivindica esta profesión quien quiere
cambiar la percepción que hay sobre la
industria
suelo decir que aquí las mujeres son más
fuertes que los hombres son trabajadoras
luchadoras con frecuencia pongo a mi
madre como ejemplo tenía cuatro hijos el
padre no estaba nos crió solo hoy me
siento orgullosa de ella
esa es una mujer luchadora y trabajadora
que día y noche se esforzaba por educar
a sus hijos
así son las mujeres en togo hoy tenemos
una primera ministra aquí en tovo
virtual donde es un orgullo para
nosotras las mujeres
es un muy buen ejemplo para nosotras
significa que las mujeres tienen
derechos tienen fuerza tienen algo que
decir es donde como el día
ser inminente también es directora de
casting para el film o el festival
internacional de moda en todo
y una responsabilidad que se toma muy en
serio y creo que en áfrica por lo
general no somos tan delgadas como las
mujeres en europa de talla 32 o 34 y la
mayoría de las modelos aquí son talla 36
o 38 es una mezcla me gustan las mujeres
que miden más de unos 74
esa es la estatura mínima y buscamos que
sean altas naturales bellas y que estén
en forma
pero para estar en sintonía con su
tiempo un festival de moda debe superar
esos estándares y proponer otros puntos
de vista privilegiar las transgresiones
[Música]
para jacques logo el fundador del filme
eso es fundamental
me gustaría enviar un mensaje como la
homosexualidad no es legal no está
permitida en áfrica sobre todo en todo
de nepal también nos gustaría mandar un
mensaje a través de esta modelo que se
llama al examen que puede ser que él o
ella sea diferente pero esa no es razón
para dejarla al margen para rechazarla
al contrario debemos apoyarla solo
porque se siente más cómoda
presentándose como un hombre no
significa que sea lesbiana para nada la
vida se trata de poder escoger sus las
dietas yo acá
se fue fugaz a su tiene 34 años su
nombre artístico es alexandra magic set
es emprendedora togolesa modelo y
andrógina
me parece que en todo hay más bien pocas
personas andrógenas realmente no he
visto muchos me he encontrado con
mujeres poco femeninas pero no son
exactamente andróginas es decir con
características tanto femeninas como
masculinas a causa de la sociedad cuando
uno es mujer necesariamente debe usar
vestidos
hay que ser femeninas pero yo adopto
ambas posturas y sesiones fotográficas
suelen ser más masculinas porque me
parece más divertido me encanta el
estilo masculino así que juego con eso
como aceptan la sociedad en todo lo
andrógino
[Música]
el cambio de mentalidad ha sido
progresivo al principio las personas
decían con el tiempo ella va a cambiar
con el tiempo su lado femenino será
dominante porque de todas maneras es una
mujer y es natural con mi familia la
aceptación fue progresiva sobre todo por
parte de la madre porque ella hubiera
querido tener una niña elegante y bonita
y mis prendas son esencialmente
masculinas pero de todas maneras lo
acepto lo que más me molesta es cuando
las personas hablan sobre uno estando
muy cerca hablan fuerte para que uno las
escuchen algunos incluso hablan sobre el
género ocurre todos los días preguntan
es un hombre es una mujer quién es quién
es simplemente una persona que ama la
moda
y la vida